all my friends saw me like fly in the
air somersault and then I landed you
didn't remember that you didn't no no
that I only saw two headlights and I
landed with my ear out like this so
that's why I was hanging out hanging
then I went to the hospital and then uh
there was a cigarette in my jacket my
mom was coming and I was like oh my God
[Laughter]
[Music]
so off camera we were talking a little
bit about how growing up in the late 90s
early 2000s as an Asian youth was sort
of synonymous with Asian gangster
lifestyle well so so so what I noticed
was like when we're the more we talk
right I'm like Ellen I'm like you're
probably our age because
the stuff that you're talking about the
references that you make I'm just like
you remind me of girls I grew up with
and then and then we find out I'm like
yeah you are you are similar to us in
age but then also you grew up in NorCal
which is miles away but at the same time
it's like I was like how is this
happening when everyone that grew up in
the same era if you're from the same
class if you're from like like meaning
like social status right like you're not
from a rich neighborhood or you're not
you didn't grow up a certain way it's
like all of us remember a violent kind
of world every day was a fight it was
crazy and then that's like it's because
earlier we talked about how like you
know rappers are dying on whatever
whatever but like right now it feels
safer for me like I feel safer yeah the
same cafes and the places that I go to
now it doesn't feel like how it used to
be because
um yeah we would be eating dinner after
like like a club or whatever and all of
a sudden a fight will break out every 10
minutes and then the shooting you have
to go home or whatever right and then
even though you're from San Francisco
area it's the same thing and when I talk
to other people our age whether it's
Chicago New York
Texas they all remember the same stuff
and I'm like that's kind of mind-blowing
because back then there wasn't like oh
why is it parallel yeah how was this
happening simultaneously all over
different communities yeah
that's interesting I mean also rap back
then was different too I remember it was
like more Tupac and Biggie I I don't
know music was different maybe that was
just the culture the culture the culture
surrounding it yeah and uh so when we're
off camera I was he was saying Rumble
and I was like thank you sir thank you
because yeah Rumble though even the term
Rumble like David so you made fun of me
years later
that's true because and it's a real way
what did he make you feel like West Side
Story or he was like yes like what what
the [ __ ] are you Rumble oh like I think
you referenced West Side Story he was
like how old are you but that's how that
was a common thing yeah we're like we're
like um I feel like it started in our
brother's generation or whatever where
they would just meet up with like 40
people on each side and just at the park
they would just go at it I never saw a
single one-on-one fight growing up
really no it would always be like big
ass
you would think they would start as
one-on-ones though sometimes they
started as one of them oh this one
started one-on-one there's never two
people just like alone I don't know I
never see people go all right let them
handle that's another thing too I
realized that when people fight they
don't really fight when it's they're
just by themselves like like okay like
in school like uh if you see your your
arch nemesis in the restroom whatever
you wouldn't just fight them by yourself
you wait to like it's like the the it's
between classes there's a crowd maybe so
there's like uh so there's evidence
maybe you don't ever fight them by as
long as you see them just [ __ ] just
you don't even [ __ ] say [ __ ] Yeah you
know I don't know what that's about we
used to talk about how like I distinctly
remember in the early 2000s that I
couldn't go anywhere without someone
trying to [ __ ] with me for no reason yes
yes that's so true kick it with people
to make sure I didn't get jumped but
that's why a lot of people join games
shopping were my friends because I have
to because I would be the quietest one
but they always knew me as a dancer girl
so I was always cool
oh you dance you dance so dancing wasn't
like today like choreographer viral no
no no you dance like oh that Asian girl
can dance like don't mess with her yeah
and that was that girl of every because
different circles yeah yeah I'm cool but
then dances have that power yes man I
had to kick it with all the girls were
like slicing their arms oh my god dude
you got the cigarette burn the
cigarettes
the lighter the little lighter smile the
little yeah two or three they would be
jumping girls right there all like
outright outside the school that had to
be their friends because I would be the
one that can be you know yeah yeah I
remember that like and that's why you
saw Asians 40 deep sometimes yeah you
remember like they would be hanging out
with like 50 people at the bowling alley
group because they all like they're like
a army of ants that has to protect
themselves and [ __ ] yeah and I saw this
all the time and then like you'll see
like 50 and 10 is going to the [ __ ]
Park
[Laughter]
like I got hit by a car got money from
that butt Integra well you got a
settlement from that full circle fish
small I mean give people that story give
people the story yeah yeah what happened
what happened so this was in Middle
School and it was my friend finding my
friend
um and they started first only then two
but it was two crowds so my friend she
has the mix crowd so that's like all
different races okay and then the other
one had the Asian one
um so they start going and it just got
big and I just remember trying to pull
off people and blah blah and then you
got the Vietnamese gang coming with the
bats and that was real like we're like
oh [ __ ] we don't have bats so we're like
we gotta [ __ ] and guys so we all book it
from the rumble
um and I'm booking it and then me and my
friend Diana were going first and my
group of friends behind me and then all
I remember was uh waking up on the
bottom of the hill and then I like got
up and I was like seeing blood I was
like yeah
oh [ __ ]
and then like my one shoe is down the
block even more
hit by a car all I saw was two
headlights all of a sudden all black
black so I was like man like I'm pretty
sure when this happens and you die like
you don't really feel nothing because I
didn't feel anything it was just black
two headlights and then all my friends
saw me like fly in the air somersault
and then I landed you didn't remember
that you didn't no I know that I only
saw two headlights and I landed with my
ear out like this so that's why I was
hanging out hanging
then I went to the hospital and then uh
there was a cigarette in my jacket my
mom was coming and I was like oh my God
[Laughter]
[Music]
my face was like a pancake like it was
this big like can you explain to your
parents what the [ __ ] happened to your
ear
I don't even know I was just caring
about the cigarette my mom walked and I
was like telling my friend like put the
sticker in the garbage can but she like
fainted I was like thank goodness put it
in the garbage your mom faints thank
goodness you're like oh okay you can't
find out yeah
I don't know what I told her but I just
remember I didn't go to school for two
weeks because my face was like oh damn
but I was that's crazy I do remember
like every day going out there was a bit
of fear of something myself someone said
something's gonna happen today well I'm
gonna [ __ ] somebody up or my friend's
gonna be an idiot yeah and then you're
just there and you're you're trying to
have a wholesome time bowling with your
friends
eat some food and somebody stabs you and
you're like why it would always be Japan
Town SF by the bowl Jay Bowl
gotta kick it my uncle lived down there
oh dude
I guarantee you I probably crossed like
one of these yeah I would be the one out
there like this smoking no oh my god do
you have pictures of yourself in that
Persona yeah
I literally let's go it's funny because
Christian looks at me right now she's
like I can't relate I'm so sorry and
then she's like do you relate and I was
like I really in a different way I also
was scared every day so instead I went
to the science room and played Magic the
Gathering during lunch
avoid the [ __ ] gangsters so you are a
part of it you were a part of it but you
stayed away from it yeah this is good I
was I was like nerdy and Pudgy enough
where I was no threat to either side
good that's good I feel like everybody
was fine with me it was just my cousin
who was annoying to them so anytime my
cousin got beef I had to be in it but
then that's when we got an imaginative
Gathering because nobody could take away
our [ __ ] love for cards I think
that's good though but you know what you
know what's the bad part about about
trying to hide in a space like that so
that's what we did with Counter-Strike
and then gangster started playing
Counter-Strike I know and gangsters
ruined it for everyone that's true
because I did have to be in the PC bang
and so you're in a room it's like a
computer Cafe right there's like 30
computers everybody's playing
Counter-Strike on a land so you're
shooting people that are also in the
room if you killed the wrong guy he
stands up and he goes who the [ __ ] is
that who shot me and you're just like
it came to the point where certain
people came they would be shootouts
because of because they ultimately
closed them because of a murder over a
country oh wow Garden Grove a guy got
stabbed with a pen was it [ __ ]
Vietnamese again yeah I have a buddy who
um was playing Counter-Strike and then
um people called in that those guys were
there so then they weren't there to play
Counter-Strike and shoot them they were
there to kill him so then once he got
once he saw them he was like holy [ __ ]
right he jumped out got into his car as
he was driving away they they went
through the back and they shot and then
he got so lucky because it hit the
corner you know where the metal part is
in the corner if the bullet hit that
first and it got lodged to the back of
his head and it melted right there and
it stopped before going through what the
[ __ ] so he just has a bump right here at
the back of his head but they couldn't
surgically pull it out because it
created like a like a crack in a hole
that well see that's the thing with what
you were saying with how you have to
roll in groups because the amount of
times I can't even count when I was by
myself and someone would just go where
you from and I would have to go nowhere
oh my god dude like I'm from nowhere and
that's just here in San Gabriel like how
much more of you in somewhere farther
away where they don't know you and then
because it's harder for me because I
didn't look nerdy but I looked like I
was trying to be cool so they'd be like
oh who the [ __ ] are you yeah nobody
oh
it's fine I would have to lie about that
[ __ ] too sometimes because like back in
the day Fullerton and Cerritos for some
reason always had the biggest beef but I
would go to I went to Sunny house in
Fullerton but my parents [ __ ] live in
Border Park so you know I'd be at
Cerritos Town Center from time to time
and these [ __ ] fools why people
always come up be like where you from
and I'm not gonna say I'm going to Sunny
Hills that sounds bad it all sounds like
I'm like I'm from Buena Park I live I'm
not in La Palma they're like all right
would you be by yourself huh would you
be by yourself I'd be like with my
cousins and stuff like that just be
stupid [ __ ] we just look like [ __ ]
nerds you know what I mean like you're
just but you just happen to be Asians
yeah in a spot that somebody deems their
territory it was just so Regional back
then did it feel like back then is it
none of this accurate I don't feel like
I ever got [ __ ] with by black dudes
white dudes it was only only Asians only
other Asians for sure I didn't really
get that much yeah it depends because I
mean gang stuff was happening everywhere
but I think if you hung out in only
Asian areas that's who's gonna [ __ ]
that's true too I like the Mexican dudes
at my school and stuff they just call
you Chino and you're cool they look
equally against it but they just were
cool and nice about it I looked Mexican
so they were cool with me I just went
with being funny bro like just being
funny being like uh like all whatever
Clique whatever Hood whatever whoever
was like like the toughest like whoever
was like a like a bull I'll try to just
be like cool with them like be funny to
where he'll be like oh he thought he's
cool don't feel like he's all right he's
all right that's why all right cool I'm
on I'm on I'm on everybody's good side
that's what that's how I was like that
was my defense mechanism you're like you
want notes from class man I got notes
from class yeah yeah like I would I
would like uh like yeah in the classroom
if there was like one of those like hard
fools in the class whatever I would just
be funny I could like I could take that
L you know I mean if like you know get
sent out to class whatever whatever but
as long as nobody's [ __ ] with me
that's like all right I'm cool you know
what I mean you know what I realized
like some of
um my friends that didn't end up in this
stuff they like they did skating extreme
sports like surfing and I feel like
there's a lot of like excitement that
young men have that with their
aggression and they need an outlet they
need something they need an activity
yeah
yeah the white kids have like the
like that's like you can relate
no no no no camera on me so uh I was
involved in many activities in high
school but they have they have like
something that that's that's adrenaline
because I think a lot of the stuff that
we were chasing was adrenaline yeah a
lot of it was like excitement doing
crazy [ __ ] that's why like I'm I'm quick
to admit that like as much [ __ ] as I got
into I willingly walked into it because
I thought it was fun but I didn't want I
just didn't want to die but I wanted to
almost die
yeah I was like this is kind of tight
it's thrilling but it but also once you
you also weren't on the same page with
your group sometimes like we would go to
a party like we went to a party in
Carson one time and then as soon as we
got there the other guys were like Hey
we're gonna steal this DJ's equipment oh
no
[Laughter]
he's like don't get the point of all
right my song request is next like damn
it I'm like what's the point of you know
getting ready looking cool and then like
we go to House parties and the first
thing you guys want to do is fight other
men I'm like I'm there I want to talk to
girls I want to [ __ ] like meet women
and you want to do the most gayest thing
on earth
you just want to go in and just fight
other men all day long and I'm like
that's Rumble
[Laughter]
why am I doing my hair that's what I
felt I was like why am I even getting
ready why but that's why people didn't
realize that those dudes were the
influencers of our day like those were
the influencers like they were the guys
calling all the shots that you just
along for the ride and [ __ ] you're like
I think well they made a game out of
like at least in LA right like kids
Grand Theft Auto they made it they made
a game out of fighting Chinatown worse
like they they literally made a game out
of fighting because like a lot of the
times it wasn't even drug like territory
money driven it was just because you
wanted to be the baddest gang so you
wanted everyone to know your name so
you're gonna do the most violent [ __ ]
fight each other and then that's why we
had the culture of gang banging where
it's like
um it's called hitting people up but you
see a group of guys that look thuggish
and then you you ask them where they're
from and if they say the gang that uh is
a rival then you gotta go at it right so
that was a com that's why Asians [ __ ]
with Asians a lot because they cared
about like oh this is my game I like
this Asian boy this is whatever right
and then so they wanted to be the
biggest name and then they created
rivalries because they would get into
senseless fights but none of it was like
a sophisticated like yo this is my drug
territory like the Mexicans had like oh
this is our territory we're selling here
you can't sell in here and it's like it
was just pointless stupid streets just
Pride stupid yeah it was Pride but I
think it's because young men had so like
these [ __ ] juveniles had so much
energy and aggression they're all we're
all getting our asses beat at the house
that's another thing too oh it's true at
home you again oh yeah so it's like
where do you where do you take that out
you're just taking it all in like
kinetic energies yeah like black panther
I always say dance truly saved my life
because I was kicking it with wild
people one because I don't want to get
my ass whooped and also I was getting
beat in the house so the only thing that
I can go to that I can look at that
dance floor was that's why when people
ask me why am I so great aggressive with
my dancing is like that's why I am so
aggressive I had so much to say but I
could never say it because I was always
crumping but she's [ __ ] yeah oh
but then that's what people always say
like you know why do you dance so
aggressive and they think it's just like
a dance thing and I'm like it's so like
it's because of the way I grew up it's
where I grew up and how you this was a
civil rights movement style built on
oppression is that what it is no I was
gonna say it's it's just
yeah I don't know it's experience like
it yeah yeah like my dance style it's
the outlet yeah it's an outlet if you
don't have an outlet then you're gonna
stay in that [ __ ] and do stupid stuff do
dumb [ __ ] so I'd rather go dance and
then dance for me was like ah it was so
fun it was crazy in that that too I had
to take the BART 12th Street Oakland and
it's like my mentors are like what the
[ __ ]
kind of just expressed and you're still
you're still getting the feeling of
being a part of a game you're a part of
a crew you gotta prove so and then you
have a leader whatever and you're doing
something tight it don't [ __ ] hurt
you know what I'm saying we're not
fighting you know what I'm saying like
they do [ __ ] like hugs yeah you know
what I mean you call Tech freestyle okay
it wasn't hugs in my mind was like you
gotta pull up because you are like Asian
like you gotta pull up because you I
might see you even being raw like you
don't know what this is so I'm like
[Music]
and then I went to um called Shock
Oakland oh and then after that with Kim
was it Kim's and then uh did you have
one after that wait Kim's my mentor like
oh okay now I get it like yes Dominique
I used to know her when she was five
um
oh gee hell yeah yeah so she's the one
that would yell at me what is that
that what is this that's a good person
to guide you though she's a strong
Yeller yeah so that's how I grew up hell
yeah and that's what I'm saying like I
get what you're saying about getting
into extreme sports I needed that energy
because I
yeah anyway did you eventually get into
dance did you have to jump out
no you know what I did is
um I slowly
convinced more than half of the people
to leave at the same time so then who's
gonna jump us out
that's that's pretty smart
yup there we go
[Music]
[Music]